tonya kinzinger alias jessica dans la
série sous le soleil a rejoint la chaîne
nrj 12 pour présenter la nouvelle saison
de la star academy avec matthieu
delormeau ils présenteront chaque jeudi
en direct le prime où les élèves seront
jugés aux côtés de stars en france est
rare d'avoir un chanteur qui s'élançait
ou un acteur qui sait danser et chanter
aux états unis est déjà dans le culture
d'avoir cette polyvalence mais sa vie un
petit à petit en france et je suis ravi
ça permet aussi parfois de se séparer
vous verrez dans le plateau qu'on serait
pas forcément toujours ensemble une
équipe peut faire un lancement et pas
l'autre ça permet d'avoir effectivement
toutes les interviews américaine ce sera
avec des artistes internationaux ce sera
pour tenir la partie de plus de
française pour moi les élèves
intégreront la star academy pour la
neuvième saison de l'émission jeudi soir
les académiciens seront révélés au
public lors du premier prime ils
découvriront alors le château de la
jeunesse situé à châteaufort bon il a
fait très froid un compte n'y était
là bas il en a fait des plateaux de la
semaine dernière là bas moi je la trouve
très belle elle est là elle est
entièrement refaite
très très moderne tout dans un look
musique jeune un peu tous nés on va dire
non à l'emprise château il en tournée et
non elle est très belle je pense qu'à
l'écran savez je fais même si certains
couleur je n'aurais pas choisi pour ses
mariages je suis allé repérer les lieux
forcément je me suis bon à ce qu'ils
vont pouvoir aller courir dans moi quel
endroit s'il pleut parce qu'on a un abri
pour pouvoir travailler il ya des
couleurs vives c'est à voir à l'entrée
dans très dur il ya rien de couleurs qui
souffre réveil au motif tard ouais ça
motive ça motive ce que c'est une
couleur très éthique leur sang
après c'est la nature du comice homme
dort donc c'est l'hiver et la neige et
tout ça coûtait quoi juste se couvrir
c'est tout vous aurez sûrement reconnu
pascal l'ancien grand frère de tf1
reconverti en coach sportif et mental
mais officiant toujours dans la télé
réalité
le but c'est qu'ils puissent tous des
pastous et tout parce qu'il ya aussi des
filles que tout le monde puisse dépasser
ses propres limites donc ça c'est
intéressant donc je vais tester très
rapidement les mythes de chacun et puis
le but c'est qu'ils puissent aller le
plus loin possible aussi bien dans le
sport que dans la tête parce que ça
c'est important il faut qu'ils aillent
vraiment talent très très fort rendez
vous le jeudi 6 décembre sur nrj 12 pour
enfin découvrir le nouvel intérieur du
château de la jeunesse à châteaufort
qu'ils sont